c'est bon
bonjour et loi on se retrouve pour ce
nouveau numéro de diagonale la leçon
bonjour bertrand bonjour à tous
diagonale de leçons nouvelle nouvelle
émission ils sont numéro 2 bon alors là
dans la première mission n'avait vu les
règles de base c'est-à-dire le mouvement
des pièces est là aujourd'hui on va voir
deux règles essentielles et parfois peu
connus pour la seconde pour le
déroulement du jeu l'échec et on va
commencer par le rock
oui le rock le rock alors qu'est ce que
c'est que le rock dont on parle
énormément au jeu d'échecs
c'est ce mouvement qui consiste à mettre
le roi en sécurité rapidement début de
la partie qui se passe en deux temps il
ya le roi et la tour et on va faire une
sorte de mouvement entre ces deux pièces
on va les intervertir le roi va donc
passer sur le côté de l'échiquier ils à
tours va aller vers le centre
alors voyons ça dans les fêtes voyons ça
dans un manoir exemple donc ici position
très simple sur l'échiquier avec le roi
blanc le roi noir toujours indispensable
au jeu d'échecs et deux tours blanches
ici le roi blanc et les tours blanches
sont sur leur case original leur case de
départ et donc le mouvement du rock ça
va être de prendre le roi de le nom je
ne me trompe
on commence par prendre la tour une des
tours ont choisi celle qu'on veut le
petit rock punk rock c'est vrai c'est
parce qu'on m'avait appris mais on prend
la tour on l'amène vers le roi ou et
vivre la case à côté du roi bonbons et
ensuite on prend le roi et on le passe
juste à côté de la tour en voyez ça va
les pièces vont tourner et pour le grand
roque c'est la même chose on prend là la
tour donc de mots ouais on l'amène vers
le roi sur cette caste des uns et le roi
lui va passer sur l'état c'est un mois
j'ai sincèrement si on va pas polémique
pendant la lgv en mer on m'avait pas
appris comme ça on m'avait dit que
c'était d'abord c'est un double
mouvement on va résumer à cette salle la
seule fois on peut toucher de pièces en
même temps c'est quand même important et
moi on m'avait dit d'abord toujours
bouger le roi de casey maître cattoir à
côté alors les deux les deux marches
c'est de se dire vernissage et que des
commencements
j'ai commencé avec la formule c'est à
dire comprendront les places de deux
cases ont fait passer la tour au dessus
et l'autre l'autre formule marche
également donc voilà un exemple très
simple de rock bon alors si un
internaute vous l'avez vu en direct
on n'est pas toujours d'accord mais
enfin voilà les règles du jeu c'est ce
que je viens de vous dire l oit alors
eloi maintenant alors à quoi ça il faut
quand même le redire cette règle
pourquoi elle est importante elle date
de depuis quand est ce que les champions
roc rapidement est-ce qu'il faut rock et
rapidement etc
ac dc oui alors le rock c'est une règle
de base du jeu d'échecs qui existe
depuis je dirais la création du jeu
enfin j'ai souvenir de dorel où on joue
aux échecs avec les dés et très très
vite s'est imposé la forme actuelle du
jeu d'échecs qui date depuis à peu près
de milan donc le rock est une règle très
ancienne maintenant est-ce que les
champions roc
oui dans 90% des cas quand il ne marque
pas ça peut être deux choses soit ils se
font déborder dans l'ouverture et c'est
à dire qu'ils n'ont pas le temps de rock
et ils se font écraser par une
préparation soit c'est un nouveau
concept très original qui marche mais
neuf fois sur dix les champions roc
puisque c'est un mouvement très très
utile qui va mettre le roi à l'abri et
qui va mener les tours vers le centre on
y reviendra tout à leur banc alors donc
mouvement utile maintenant les règles
est ce qu'il ya quand même des règles
spécifiques au rock
oui le rock n'est pas toujours possible
mais le rock avec avec un s au rock avec
un s
le voilà c'est pas toujours autorisé de
roque et il ya des cas où ça ne marche
pas alors on va en montrer un tout de
suite si on peut voilà cette position
c'est la même position que précédemment
sauf qu'il est un fou noir un fou noir
en e3 donc oui si on l'a dit la dernière
fois dans notre émission précédente sur
le déplacement des pièces le fou se
déplaçant diagonale donc le fou
contrôler les cases pointé en verre ici
alors ça ça crée un petit problème pour
le rock puisque si les blancs vous les
rockets le roi passerait sur la 4g un
hula cas c'est un c'est à dire les case
verte ici qui sont maintenant rouge
qui sont contrôlés par le feu ou trois
ans et ça nos échecs c'est pas possible
on n'a pas le droit de mettre leur
reprise ça on revient on n'a pas le
droit de mettre le roi donc en échec
emprise c'est la même chose on revient
comme si on peut voir d'autres règles
qu'on a vu rapidement la dernière fois
aux échecs on peut pas mettre leur
emprise donc si un requin mêleront
emprise ben c'est pas c'est interdit ça
veut dire qu'on n'a pas le rendrait donc
ici c'est un exemple très simple où les
blancs n'ont le droit n'ont pas droit
d'euros qu'ils ont besoin d'effectuer ni
le petit rock ni le coq d'accord le fou
contrôle ans et de 15 quand les petits
rock c'est du côté où on est du côté roy
un oui un grand roque ses côtés dame
enfin côté il y avait la dame au début
de la fin voilà c'était un petit coq ces
petits parce qu'il ya deux cases entre
le roi et la tour grand roque ces grands
parce qu'il ya trois cases voilà c'est
mieux encore c'est bio dit c'est plus
didactique
alors elle continue un autre exemple
alors plus compliqué cette fois un
puisque la donc nous il ya deux pièces
noires qui ont été rajoutés
on va rappeler les cases qu'elle
contrôle il ya le fourbe et 5 qui
contrôle cette diagonale
donc on rappelle un toujours c'est le
foot donc contrôler les diagonales
voilà le fou contrôle donc la case f1
entre autres et le cavalier qui est ici
contrôler la casse d un accord et la
case b1 d'accord donc voilà donc
beaucoup de beaucoup de casse contrôler
ces trois cases rouges sont contrôlés
donc j'ai mentionné seulement les cases
sur la première rangée puisque pour le
rock c'est celle qui nous intéresse
dacca que les choses soient incessant de
braekeleer goethe interrompt mais ce
sont les gaz qui sont entre le roi et
les tours qui sont importantes pour les
règles du rock c'est ça pour savoir si
on a le droit d'effectuer le petit
recouvrance est alors ici simplement on
a le droit de faire ni l'un ni l'autre
alors pourquoi parce que quand on
effectue le mouvement du rock on
considère que le roi va aller pas à pas
vers la case g1 ou vers la case c1 dames
a effectué un pas puis un autre et là en
l'occurrence il ne peut pas passer par
cette case f1 qui est contrôlé
par le fou donc pas de petit rock donc
interdiction interdiction totale de
passer par la case interdiction et c'est
à dire que si par exemple les blancs
faisait petit rock et après les noirs
prennent comme il pourra le faire la
tour avec le fou non ça c'est ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas ça n'existe
absolument pas dans le côté rock n'est
pas possible dans des positions quand
ces cas là par exemple monde et concret
il ya un votre votre adversaire veut
faire petit rock vous lui dites c'est un
coup impossible vous l'empêcher de faire
petit rock oui ça que ça veut dire oui
tout à fait ce n'est pas comme aux dames
je sais plus comment une expression ici
je vois là souffler n'est pas jouer ici
n'y a pas de ça il n'existe pas non plus
aux dogmes qui n'existe pas non plus
donc effectivement le petit rock
simplement le joueur reprendra son coup
et jours à autre chose alors pour le
grand roque
ouais il est identique la casse des uns
étant sous contrôle
la case que je l'aï ci étant contrôlé
par le cavalier c'est impossible de rock
est en revanche un point important si la
case dr n'avaient pas été contrôlées
donc si la case d1 était simplement si
si elle le cavalier dépensé 3 1 avec la
casse bien serait été contrôlés mais pas
la casden là ça serait possible de re ok
alors pourquoi parce que la tour pour
passer de la case 1 à la casse des 1 n'a
pas besoin n'est pas mise en échec
c'est ça le truc n'est pas contrôlée
d'accord donc la casse bien en fait
n'est pas un local facteurs n'empêchent
pas et c'est donc le parcours du roi qui
est important ce n'est pas le parcours
de la tour c'est le parcours du roi qui
prime et c'est l'expression quand on
fait ça s'est passé sous mettra les
grands maîtres s'est passé sous 1 échecs
passés sous intéressé c'est un échec
c'est marqué dans le braquage par guerre
des échecs des tartes etc au vert bon
bon livre pour les débutants et pas que
pour les débutants d'ailleurs donc ici
aucun des deux rock n'est possible
puisque les cases à côté du roi sont
contrôlés précédemment on a vu qu'ils
vont arriver sur une caisse d'échec
c'était pas possible non plus donc ça
c'est les interdictions du rock il y en
a d'autres
on part a continué avec un exemple tout
de suite d'accord donc exemple simple on
va passer sur les premiers coups donc le
déroulement de la partie on l'a déjà
d'expliquer la dernière fois les blancs
jouent les noirs jouent et les ainsi de
suite
chacun son tour de jouer donc les blancs
commence par ouvrir avec l'option le roi
t as beaucoup ouverture tout à fait
classique et reconnu un très bon coup
cinq caisses un très bon coup oui il
faut contrôler le centre de sa permet le
développement des pièces on va vite là
dessus des 4 donc là coup logique
cela dit mais un peu atypique logique
puisqu'on fait un duo pion central et ça
permet la sortie rapide des deux fous
notamment qui pourront sortir très vite
mais pas forcément le meilleur coup dans
cette position des six avait
complètement sain logique aussi on
défend le club ont défendu le point e 5
donc ici si on prend le syndic
conception et puis on prend un anglais
structure totalement symétrique et là à
l'amsterdam échec échec échec au roi
ça serait mal d'ailleurs si la dame des
huit étaient défendus mad men ne l'est
pas il permet donc roi prend des vite
hélas hélas le roi noir à bouger ça veut
dire que en lait en l'état il ne peut
par ok il ne peut pas ou ne peut plus
alors il ne pourra plus jamais revoir à
jamais rock et après avoir bougé
on ne peut plus jamais avoir bougé droit
ou la tour il n'a plus droit possible
mais entre nous un petit exemple aux
attaques continuelles à part toi
lorsqu'il ya une anecdote fantastique on
va continuer les cards off on va
continuer pour exposer bien le bien le
problème
cavalier c3 donc la découpe
développement toujours ça on y viendra
dans la leçon numéro 3 et 4 c'est à dire
qu'il faut prendre les cases centrale
quatre mêmes films de vince c'est un
principe qui n'a pas d' avec n'a pas de
limites
photo 3 rapidement sortir les pièces des
remarques que le roi noir est revenu sur
sa caisse d'origine
voilà qu'avec trois fous des six alors
là les blancs n'ont pas de soucis ils
n'ont bougé ni le roi ni la tour la case
des uns et pas contrôlé la casse c'est
un n'est pas contrôlé vers les deux
cases là ne sont pas contrôlés donc on
peut donc pas de problème grand roque
les bons joubran est alors bhv petit
rock alors voilà maintenant petit rôle
pour les noirs ce n'est pas possible
pourtant la casa fuite est libre elle
n'est pas contrôlée
lacasse g8 n'est pas contrôlée n'est
plus mais le roi noir ayant déjà bougé
fine il est impossible rockets c'est
clair il faut pas que la tour ni leroy
et bouger voilà tout à fait hier par
contre effectivement si la tour droite
avait bougé on aurait pu croquer du côté
gauche
évidemment on a ainsi une tour à bouger
on peut encore roque et de l'autre côté
d'accord d'accord
bon bah c'est clair je leur dis
peut-être rapidement donc le rock c'est
un double mouvement entre le roi et les
tours leroy bouche de deux cases la tour
ça d'un côté un toi tu dis ça
différemment mais tu amènes leurs romans
et puis c'est un coup très important
parce que ça permet de développer les
pièces et m leroy laverie je crois que
voilà l'oral qui a été à mon avis bien
mais on reviendra on reviendra sur parce
que c'est un coup très très encore une
fois je crois que c'est un coup très
important il faut pas avoir peur je
crois que tu va nous raconter l'anecdote
sur karpov et faut pas avoir peur de pas
s'être souvenu de toutes les règles et
racontons un petit peu cette histoire
oui alors effectivement j'ai entendu
dire qu'à nathalie karpov
jouer contre victor cornouaille à un
match de championnat du monde et victor
cornouaille a un doute à un moment je on
sait pas ce qui s'est passé de la
prennent partie longue et éprouvante
il demande à l'arbitré s'il a le droit
de rock est dans une position gagnante
ils arrivent vers l'arbitré dit monsieur
arbitre ce que vous pensez que je peux
effectuer le petit rock dans cette
position alors bon ça tours étaient
attaqués mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
un critère la tour attaqué c'est pas
grave ça n'empêche pas le rock mec est
donc finalement leur but que le v10 pas
de problème vous pouvez ok finalement il
n'a pas évoqué la gagner la partie
donc l'honneur nan c'est compliqué mais
c'est une règle importante
oui alors notons au passage
effectivement chose qu'on a oublié de
dire on ne peut pas re ok quand on est
en échec
harry et voilà un alors alors la
dernière question on n'a pas le droit
d'invoquer quand on est en échec mais
quand on a été une fois échec
est-ce qu'on a droit de retrait après
non ça ne poserait plus de problème si
vous êtes et chaque et que vous paraît
l'échec sans bouger votre roi d'accord
il y aura plus de problème vous pour
évoquer au coup d'après d'accord donc
pas bougé le roi ni la tour pour avoir
bloqué toute la partie et ne pas être en
échec bon on reviendra ou reviendra là
dessus mais mais déjà c'est une règle
hyper importante
alors maintenant on va arriver vers le
deuxième sujet bah on va reparler du
pion et des règles spéciales du pion un
sas est aussi c'est aussi un paradoxe du
jeu d'échec c'est que vous avez bien
compris que la dame était la pièce la
plus simple la plus puissante et que le
roi est l aps la plus importante est que
les pions bas sont des pièces sont des
comment on peut te sens des wii sont des
pièces très important disons que les
pions sont l'âme des et chaillot d'après
philidor la dernière fois on avait passé
assez rapidement sur le mouvement du
pion ici on va sans s'y atteler un peu
plus avec pour commencer une position
assez simple toujours les deux rois sur
l'échiquier un pion blanc qui est bien
avancée et d'options noir est donc là on
va exposer la donc d'abord va rappeler
ce que le pion avance tout droit de une
case ou deux cases s'il est encore sur
sa case de
en case de départ à n'importe quel
moment de la partie voilà un pas en
champions 17 donc pour les noirs l'a pas
bouger encore il est resté sur premier
rang et là ça lui donne le droit
d'avancer de deux cases d'accord peut
également avancer que d'une case mais
dis donc
et une fois que pierre boucher ce qui
est le cas de ces options ici un f6 lui
ne peut avancer plus que d'une seule une
seule case à la fois avancé mais que
leur case par case
l'objectif du pion bien sûr c'est
d'arriver à promotion c'est à dire
d'arrivée d'atteindre la dernière rangée
du camp adverse
nous les noirs se transformer en dames
et au passage le pion donc ne prend pas
tout droit ne prend pas la pièce qui est
devant lui mais la pièce qui est sûr
c'est sur les côtés là il prend en
diagonale d'options lemonade la leçon
ils viennent ici donc position simple
option blanc d'options noir considérons
que ce soit au noir de jouer voilà les
coups possibles premier coup pion
prendront ces voix là c'est certainement
ici le ver un coup dans la pose et si
c'est tout à fait incertain dans la
position maintenant
donc tu en prends pions gagne un pion
effectivement l'option été reprise autre
coût possible
jouer le pion ici le pion 17
on peut la mener en d6 naker ça serait
une faute
bien entendu puisque là ça se mettrait
sous le feu du pions blancs sont blancs
viendrait prendre en diagonale toujours
donc là on voit bien que l'option prend
en diagonale maintenant nouveaux cas on
va enlever c'est tout c'est toutes ces
traces voilà alors non c'est un petit
peu laborieux tout ça l'option 17 avance
de 2 pas d'accord on est en fin de
partie peu avant ses deux parrains ils
peuvent ainsi si elle peut toujours
avancer de pain est ici qu est ce qui
peut se passer on considère à ce moment
là que l'option a fait un pas puis un
autre comme le roi quand il fait le
petit rock ainsi dire qu'il a joué ça
puis ça et donc le pion blanc qui est
ici a le droit de passer le ramasser
donnant est passé le prendre
ce qui donnera donc ce résultat-là
l'option avance 1
et à et à quoi la banque c'est la prison
passant si on l'a pris en passant il
obtient disparu c'est quand même dingue
mais moins connu est loin effectivement
c'est une des règles que j'ai apprise le
plus tard d'ailleurs j'avais un doute
sur la présentation je me savais pas ce
que c'était et c'est ça en fait c'est
tout simplement le pion avance de
d'occase et l'option qui est à côté peut
le prendre en considérant qu'il vient de
passer comme s'ils avaient avancé que
d'une seule case oui moi je dois
admettre aussi que j'ai commencé à jouer
vers 12 ans a été gens qui jouaient plus
des années depuis des années et qui
jouait pas si mal que ça et il
connaissait pas la règle de la prise en
passant et moi je l'avais lu rapidement
et je l'avais mal comprise je croyais
qu'avec le pion on pouvait prendre aussi
les pièces donc on va quand même
s'arrêter sur cette reiki est peu
commune peuvent un peu connu un peu et
qui est très importante comme on va le
voir
alors je crois que tu a concocté pour
nous un exemple qui nous permet de bien
comprendre l'intérêt de cette prise oui
tout à fait donc là on va on n'y a rien
position compliquée vous voyez beaucoup
beaucoup de matériel etc est un terrain
compliqué mais les blancs une tour de
plus qu'en mai oui alors voilà il ya
huit pions pour tout le monde
les blancs ont une tour ici que les
noirs n'ont pas être donc ici on
considère que c'est aux noirs de jouer
puisque pour les blancs le gain se
tiendrait assez facilement pourquoi il
suffirait de jouer le pion à 4 ans à 5,6
vie de la prise en b 6 d'accord vous
voyez ce parcours du psion les noirs ne
peuvent rien faire dans cette position
ils ont juste un roi à bouger c'est pas
suffisant on avance
ensuite on prend le pion en b 6 la tour
obtient une colonne d'entrée et l'a
ensuite va passer derrière les pions et
va commencer a tout ramassé évidemment
la tour qui se déplacent verticalement
et horizontalement va faire un régal va
faire un carnage parmi les points noirs
donc le plan de gains pour les blancs
est très simple la deviendra sur cette
position parce que ça paraît simple mais
peut-être que pour le débit évidemment
pour le joueur déjà guéri c'est ça
mais pour le débutant pur lfd
dialectique alors comment peut-on faire
pour les noirs pour se battre contre ce
vos plans alors voilà les joueurs
voilà les noirs on compte ici une belle
option dont une belle option c'est de
prendre le pion à 7
ouais et de l'avant c'est ici sur 7 15
ans à 5 et et qu'est-ce que ça fra bat
sable apparemment ça bloque la
positionne ça bloque complètement la
position puisque les pions ne prennent
pas devant eux prennent en diagonale
mais ici il n'ya plus rien apprendre en
diagonale élections ne peuvent plus
avancer la tour elf marchand colonnes
elle va être bloquée par ses propres
pions pourra donc pas passer de l'autre
côté du camp noir et pareil pour le roi
donc ici après le coup à cette a5 des
noirs malgré l avantage énorme de
matériel c'est à dire une tour de plus 5
points 5 points y a pas de solution pour
gagner donc ici les noirs s'ils jouent à
7 à 5
il semblerait qu'il fasse nul et c'est
là qu'intervient la prise un pavage en
passant voilà puisque sur ce coup à 7 à
on fait exactement là considérations
habituelles l'option est passé par la
case à 6 ça ça ne marche qu'avec les
pions c'est la prise en passant c'est
uniquement pour les pions bien le
préciser est donc sûre sur ce coup à 7 à
on prend ici en passant c'est à dire on
joue le pion b5 on le met sur la casa 6
et on enlève le pion à 5 dans un
deuxième temps de l'échiquier on appris
en passant ensuite effectivement des
colonnes vont s'ouvrir notamment la
colonne b la colonne a va s'ouvrir aussi
la tour va passer et on va gagner
on était donc philosophiquement l'idée
la prise en passant c'est que ça empêche
les positions de se bloquer et ça
contrebalance le double pas du pion oui
oui ça c'est le
je dirais c'est l'idée philosophique de
la prise en passant voilà mais c'est un
truc important c'est à dire bon alors
c'est vrai que c'est d'une certaine
manière c'est plus difficile que toutes
les autres actes parce que la lettre
virtuelle qui comprend quelque chose qui
n'est pas sur sa case par case échec on
prend toujours sur la case oui oui c'est
la seule et unique exception à cette
règle
effectivement quand on prend une pièce
le mouvement arrive on prend la pièce et
on se met sur la case de la pièce la
présentation c'est pas ça effectif un
peu prendre comme aux dames on passe en
passant c'est ça madame bon en tout cas
c'est une rect hyper importante alors
on va voir maintenant un exemple de
début de partie où c'est important on a
vu un exemple de fin de partie que c'est
plus qu'important parce qu'encore une
fois malgré la tour de moins s'il n'y
avait pas la prise en passant après sept
à cinq cellules tout à fait alors plus
ou moins en paix nous voyons la suite un
exemple depuis la position initiale du
jeu d'échecs
alors donc cette fois ci eu quatre aussi
c'est une ouverture française défense
française d4 d5 donc toujours toujours
là il ya une constante dans les premiers
coups de la partie on y reviendra
ces avancées ces deux duos de pions les
pions du roi et de la dame puisque ça
permet le développement rapide de toutes
les pièces de 5 c 5
ces trois donc là vous voyez un petit
concept de chaîne d'options qui peut
intervenir
l'action se défendre mutuellement ça
c'est une idée qui reviendra t à regret
surtout dans ta bouche beaucoup les
pions un tout ça c'est très important
amel étions les pions ça fait tout ça
congestionne sa congestionne tout là
toute la partie donc c'est très
important ici à une chaîne de pions les
tours se défendent eux mêmes et ça c'est
bien qu'ils essaient six cavaliers f3
donc là tout se tient d'anne decis et
maintenant les blancs vont faire un plan
original
ils vont se dire je vais prendre de
l'espace côté gauche et pour cela ils
jouent au 6e coup le coup à deux à trois
marqueurs
l'idée c'est au coup suivant de jouer
l'option b 2 ans b 4 en fait c'est de
gagner de l'espace
simplement ce pion aura avancé on aura
pris de la place pour mettre des pièces
derrière les pions
donc ça c'est l'idée l'idée des blancs
des beurs et là les noirs trouve un
moyen original d'empêcher ce coup il
joue ses 5 ans et 4
alors là non explique nous alors qu'est
ce qui se passe pas sans effet b4
allaire possible ouais mais là ça donc
on vient de voir que l'option vient
d'avancer de deux cases
car qui dit à un ennemi vient de passer
devant le pis on sait qu'un vient de
passer devant tuant ses quatre et donc
après donc ça rend possible et bien
c'est kate effet que voilà le genre c4
franche tranche pas c'est trop et là
c'est grave
oui ben là là c'est assez grave puisque
déjà on a perdu d'un pion d'accord et
ensuite on va probablement perdre la
partie c'est à dire qu'à niveau quand m
cette position ne fait plus aucun aucun
doute les noirs vont gagner très bien
bon ben je pense que la prise en passant
en tout cas si c'est la première fois
que vous en attendez parler eh ben il
faut faire s'accrocher faut l'utiliser
et puis on reviendra d'accord d'accord
alors on a parlé alors
on a parlé du drake spécial aujourd'hui
pardon du rock et d'april en passant à
tout à l'heure tu m'as fait une
réflexion philosophique sur sur ces 2
sur 7 de règles souviens-tu oui oui tout
à fait alors donc comment se rappeler un
moyen simple de se rappeler quand c'est
possible et quand c'est pas possible
c'est on considère le passage le passage
des pièces on l'a dit déjà plusieurs
fois pour le rock c'est le roi qui passe
et pour la prise en passant c'est le
pion qui passe c'est à dire qu'ils vont
sur des cases sans fin en passant par la
case mais sans y être vraiment et c'est
ça qui congestionnent le fait que ça
soit possible ou pas alors pour le rock
c'est le roi qui se déplacent de deux
cases
donc s'il ya une de ces deux cas ce qui
est contrôlé aussi le roi est en échec
c'est pas possible d'appeler de rock
mecque pour la prise en passant l'on
considère que tu on passe sur une case
et ensuite arrive sur l'autre on
considère qu'il est passé sur cette case
et ça rend possible la prise en passant
d'accord on a vu là c'était très sympa
un exemple concret sur sur la prise en
passant un exemple concret de rock
intelligent dans le début de partie est
ce que tu peux s'était tu m'avais parlé
de l'amélioration de fisher espagnol on
parle peu entre nous c'est une autre
c'est notre langage de cuisine
alors maintenant le rock l'importance du
rock
oui donc on y arrive on avait les règles
la voilà dans tout cela c'est celle là
alors effectivement alors ici c'est donc
ça c'est une explication simplement du
rock
pourquoi pourquoi il est si important et
pour quoi s'est jouée par les plus
grands champions et peut être même par
le plus grand le plus grand champion en
l'occurrence bobby fischer cavaliers f3
donc là on joue pas des cartons
joucaviel 3 qu'un coup un peu plus
sérieux ça c'est des bons coups un peu
cela on l'a montré parce que dans un cas
il faut montrer les bons coups au monde
effectivement là c'est un exemple très
bon quand les blancs et pour les noirs
sa caisse et 6 on défend le bureau 5-fu
b55 donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
partie espagnole
alors faut pas avoir peur de notre
jargon espagnol parce que le premier
joueur qu'il a étudiés c'est un espagnol
qui s'appelait rouleau paix foule au gaz
et au xvème siècle voilà donc c'est une
ouverture qui date mais qui est vraiment
d'actualité puisque c'est s'est pour
l'instant les plus gros débat théorique
entre karpov et kasparov notamment à 6
et là c'est l'idée originale de fisher
moralement le four par fisher a dit non
je prends le cavaliere est ce qu il
pense au coup suivant qui est très
important voilà tu en france et 6 forcé
et au 5e ou déjà dès le 5ème roue bobby
fischer peu rauque et donc voyez très
simplement avantages du rock
on le voit ici c'est que le roi est
maintenant plein de sécurité il ya plus
du tout de courants d'air il ya trois
pions devant lui il ya ce cavalier qui
est le défend la tour qui est là
également donc oui il ya une masse de
pièces devant le roi deuxième avantage
c'est justement cette tour qui
maintenant va pouvoir passer directement
vers le centre et ça c'est bon aussi
puisqu'une tour au centre c'est très
fort et ça c'était réellement au moment
où il a joué c'était une escale à une
amélioration c'était là c'était vraiment
considéré comme un excellent coup et
c'était très tôt oui oui oui oui
béchir a plus ou moins inventé le petit
rock dans cette position donc maintenant
ça y est c'est à la mode ça fait l'objet
de débats théoriques et ainsi de suite
ainsi de suite et toi ton conseil ces
drogues et rapidement c'est près pareil
rock c'est quoi mon conseil c'est alors
on peut pas savoir si c'est la poule qui
fait l'offre ou love qui fait la poule
toujours est il qu'il faut faire deux
choses il faut sortir les pièces et
rockets alors est-ce qu'il faut sortir
les pièces pour ok ou roque et après
avoir sorti les pièces c'est la même
chose de toute façon il faut recréer
rapidement mettre l'europe à l'abri et
sortir les pièces et le sens je crois
que sur le rock on a eu pas mal de
choses une récréation un peu une petite
distraction pour finir voilà on va
passer donc la récréation alors la
récréation on a décidé que ce serait de
montrer des maths on va revenir
évidemment sur le mat on peut pas tout
faire dans une leçon mais parce que le
mat c'est le quand même le but c'est ce
qui nous fait plaisir c'est ce qu'on
recherche aux échecs exactement le matin
indispensable aux échecs donc là on va
vous montrer en une petite miniature une
partie qui se termine très vite et donc
payant il ne reste plus beaucoup de
temps donc on va aller très vite voilà
que quatre des six des quatre encore ce
duo tion pour les blancs toujours très
classique
cavani m6 fait une menace le cavalier
saute on l'a déjà dit au dessus au
dessus de questions en train de dire et
vient attaquer le pion central donc il
faut lever des fonds en forme des formes
développement une pièce en sortant une
pièce avec moi j'ai 6 donc là on veut
sortir le fou on vous le mettre sur
cette caste g7
on appelle ça en fille en quête hausse
et un développement un peu atypique mais
qui existe quand même le développement
du fou en fouillant piétons
mais peur qu'ils avaient des f3 les
blancs s'est séparé d'un logis parfait
un fou j'ai 7 pouces et quatre donc là
les blancs sortie de trois pièces ils
ont fait le développement qu'on apprend
à l'école on a créé deux cavaliers le
vous hélas hélas les noirs font une
faute puisque les noirs peuvent voter
1 le bon coup c'était le beaucoup c'est
petit ronald à ici il n'ya pas deux il
ya pas de problème il faut rockets parce
que c'est possible il ya aucun
inconvénient à ça et ça mettra l'euro à
l'abri à la place les noirs jouent ce
coup qui avait dit b17 bon hélas la
punition est immédiate
les blancs auraient pu rockets mais ils
ont vu mieux ils jouent le coup à eux
quatre
5 donc ça ça attaque le cavaliere même
si ce trek l'erreur donc coût possible
pour les noirs tu reprends pions si on
prend pions réitérant la taxe sur ce
cavalier
maintenant si lecavalier 17 vient
prendre ces options aux 5 on répliquera
simplement par cavalier prend cavani qui
aura gagné donc un cavalier contre un
pion c'est à dire la partie donc
lecavalier 6 doit partir il va
logiquement j'écarte il a ça laisse
aller à pas mal pour les noirs parce
qu'ils attaquent un nombre de fois
incalculable pure et simple
le cx-5 il est attaqué par trois pièces
voilà les trois pièces vert et attax
options ou 5 mais là le drame arrive le
tram le drame du roi qui l'a par ok
voilà fou preuve cet échec donc le roi
vient prendre le fou et maintenant on
refait un échec avec un saut de
cavaliers ont g5 donc là ça va assez
vite c'est l'exemple final c'est moins
vous pouvez le revoir en revenant sur la
barre de sur la barre de realplayer
cavaliers j'ai cinq échecs et là
plusieurs possibilités notamment par
exemple le croate 8
ouais c'est une possibilité et cavadee
e500 ou ou héroïne à sanaa rahmane c'est
une fourchette c'est une attaque le roi
et attaque la dame et pas n'importe
quelle fourchette royal alors que le
cavalier vous voyez qui va vers le roi
il va vers la dame double menace
il faut bouger droit et au coup d'après
le cavalier prend la dame dernière une
petite dernière
dernière possibilité le roi blanc j'ai
vite et là c'est la punition immédiate
dam des cinq échecs au roi ait fait des
chèques ale adam vient donc comme un fou
c
on interpose un pion on essaye en tout
cas d'approbation échapper le roi doit
partir en fuite est maintenant de mettre
cet échec et mat
pourquoi la dame est défendue par le
cavalier elle attaque le roi et le roi
ne peut pas s'en aller une variante du
mas du berger une vente du mat du berger
qu'on a vu la dernière fois donc je
pouvais revenir à l'émission de la
dernière fois on sent on est aussi
passionné que vous je crois qu'on est
obligé de se dire au revoir
on vous dit au revoir à la semaine
prochaine en tout cas chers internautes
merci
me